the mushroom is illegal in sweden
the mushroom is illegal in norway
it could be lethal but if you treat it
right it's a delicacy
there's two recorded deaths of eating
the false moral
they look like something from an alien
movie
but it's delicious
[Music]
my name is kim mikola i'm a chef owner
of restaurant inari one michelin star
here in helsinki finland
false morals they have a neurotoxins in
them that will go directly into your
liver some people get dizzy some people
you know start feeling nauseated
we're gonna make sure that we are
preparing the mushroom proper
first you put it in the cold water you
soak it at least an hour or so
after this you blanch it in hot water
the government regulations is two times
five minutes to a ratio of 250 grams of
mushroom to two liters of water
you need to change the water and then
you need to rinse the mushrooms
thoroughly after every single blanch if
treated right it's very good acidic a
bit nutty it has that kind of forest
mushroom flavor very very umami rich
falls more can be expensive 250 grams
goes around seven euros
some people are so obsessed with the
mushroom that if they cannot get it
locally here they will dry for like
hundreds of kilometers just go and get
that mushroom
is it worth all the effort that's a good
question
it is a very elegant delicacy
people of certain age really enjoy it
and they want to have it every year
i hope that people like me could kind of
give it to the younger people to prolong
tradition as well so the tradition
doesn't get forgotten
you